Trey get down the corner Trey over here
with us these guys got to encourage you
to go to the league they do well who
going to win the jump ball Victor that
dude
tall woo
Tre turn that boy around had the boy
looking out the
way
[Applause]
waa remember real real quiet
oh
trash man hey man I just watching
Malcolm X today that's crazy your boy my
man midy midy that's all I got left I
can hit that far I hit the layup right
now I SC every time I played against NBA
player they ain't got no Scout report on
me Victor in the game I'm in the game
wow how many puss that boy just had make
another show me you bad I like that
move
how you doing how you doing man good to
see
[Applause]
you yeah now we need
it I take
that the game
lit oh we got him we got him thank you
for taking me to the game father you're
welcome man man I'm thankful that I got
a cool son that can hang out with me
that I can that I have a that I can
do